now it's hard to believe that in less
than just 12 months joe biden's
popularity has absolutely crumbled
most of the self-proclaimed experts on
cable news probably expected the exact
opposite from a president with control
of both chambers of congress but that's
precisely what has happened
americans have grown tired of joe biden
and they're turning on him that's not a
gas or speculation
according to almost every poll from
gallup to reuters and everything in
between
approval for joe biden has dropped
significantly in the last year
so just today rasmussen's daily
presidential tracking poll
shows 58 percent of americans disapprove
of joe biden's performance as president
and according to a recent mars pbs poll
just a meager 29 of independence approve
of joe biden
you'd be hard-pressed to find a majority
of any demographic group that thinks joe
biden is doing a good job
now even cnn recently conceded that
biden's low poll numbers quote are not
an exception for biden at this point but
rather the rule
it's hard to say in any given day if joe
biden is aware of his low poll numbers
on some days he doesn't seem to even
know he's the president
but on the rare day that joe biden is
mentally present poll numbers are not
something he you know really pays
attention to
how much do you pay attention to
approval ratings
well not anymore
[Applause]
i appreciate the odyssey yeah
you would think the president of the
united states would engage in some
self-reflection
is if
his approval ratings started to tank in
such a short time frame but he hasn't
joe biden has doubled down on his
divisive policies so when joe biden says
he doesn't pay attention to approval
ratings he's also telling us something
else
he's saying he doesn't care enough to
change he doesn't care to unify the
country he keeps dividing
it's not the presidency that joe biden
promised this last year in the election
i pledge to be a president
who seeks not to divide
but unify
who doesn't see red states of blue
states
only sees the united states
the bible tells us
to everything there is a season
a time to build a time to reap and a
time to sow and a time to heal
this is the time to heal in america
so how is healing america coming along
well we don't have to guess
after a year of living through joe
biden's policies
millions of americans have used their
first amendment right to tell us exactly
how they feel about him
uh
[Applause]
chants like that occurred all across the
country this year until they evolved
into the euphemism
let's go brandon never before in modern
american history has a phrase been
specifically invented commercialized and
repeated to insult the president no
matter how silly or serious you think
the phrase is it has now hit
embarrassingly new heights for joe biden
thanks to a man named jared schmeck
even on christmas eve while he was
taking calls from the public and
tracking santa claus
joe biden couldn't escape let's go
brandon
you guys have to be in bed by nine
o'clock you know and asleep between nine
and 12 or he doesn't show up
this isn't to you jared this is to the
kids that's right
i hope you have a wonderful appreciation
yeah i hope you guys have a wonderful
christmas as well uh merry christmas and
let's go brandon let's go brandon i
agree hey by the way where are you in
oregon
that clip is now a viral sensation so
naturally biden's allies in the media
they've swooped into his defense
it doesn't matter that jared schmeck
claims he said let's go brandon justin
jast blue czech journalists were
outraged nbc news was traumatized by the
call and ran a headline calling the
phrase a quote
right wing slur abc news called that a
quote verbal insult
and congressman eric swalwell of all
people who has repeatedly slept with a
chinese spy
had the audacity to accuse schmeck of
humiliating his family end up being
quote indecent
meanwhile instead of talking about joe
biden's performance
cnn took the opportunity to attack
anyone who dares to utter the phrase
let's go brandon because at cnn let's go
brandon it's all about insurrection
yeah look i you know it's ungracious
it's juvenile reprehensible by the
father uh but i don't think it's
fundamentally about incivility i think
it is fundamentally about insurrection
um you know i don't know the the
individual but the the whole let's go
brandon kind of motif is a reflection of
the view two-thirds of the republican uh
base
driven by trump's claims uh false claims
and the big lie that biden is an
illegitimate president hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else